[موسيقى]
مساء الخير سؤال يشغل الاغاني الكثيرين ما
سر اسرار الغرب والحافه للترويج لحقوق
المثليين والمتحولين جنسيا هذا الالحاح
واضح جدا في اشكاله المختلفه ولا يمكن ان
تخطئه عين يعني مثلا من النادر ان ترى
دراما تم انتاجها حديثا خصوصا على المنصات
الشهيره زين وغيرها الا ويتم اقتحام
شخصيات الممثليه فيها اقامه وبعض الاعمال
بتذهب الى اكثر من ذلك وتصر على عرض
المشاهد الحميميه لهذه الشخصيات ممكن يكون
في فيلم او دراما قصته الاساسيه هو شخص
مثلي ده مفهوم لكن انا ما بتكلمش عن كده
انا بتكلم
على دراما يمكن ان تكون ناجحه دون اقامهم
في اعمال دراميه مسلسلات نجح الجزء الاول
والثاني والثالث لما انتجت اجزاء جديده
منها مؤخرا تم اقام شخصيات مثليه ومتحولين
جنسيا فيها
المساله لا تقتصر على الدراما الخاصه
بالكبار ولكن حتى افلام الكرتون
والقصص الاطفال الشهيره اللي كنا بنستمتع
بقراءتها حين كنا اطفال مثل همم بيوتي
اندبيس اعيد انتاجها لتركز على هويات
جنسيه مختلفه للشخصيات القدره الكرتونيه
المحبوبه للاطفال
مؤسسات كبيره وشركات يعني ضخمه باتت تخصص
كوتا للمثليين والمتحولين جنسيا يعني تعين
نسبه من موظفيها من
المثليين الامثله كثيره لكن المثال الاشهر
هي اداره الرئيس بيدن اللي عينت عدد كبير
جدا من المثليين والمتحولين في معهد اسمه
معهد فكتري وهذا معهد مهتم بحقوق المثليين
ويراقب يعني همم حقوقهم قال انه لغايه
ابريل 2021 ونشر بالاسماء ضمت اداره بين
اكثر من 200 من المثليين والمتحولين جنسيا
بعضهم طبعا نعرفهم جميعا زي بيتر بول وزير
النقل اللي كان ضابط سابق فيه البحريه
الامريكيه ثم اصبح واذيرا نقل واصر ان
يشكر وهو يعرف خطته لتطوير قطاع نقل زوجه
على الهواء لدعمه له في مهمته وطبعا عندنا
السيده كارين المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
وغيرهم الاتحادات الرياضيه بتمارس ضغوطا
هائلا على الدول اللي بتستضيف احداث
رياضيه كبيره حتى تسمح للمثليين بان ياتوا
الى هذه البطولات رافعين اعلامهم وتسمح
لهم بالتظاهر دفاعا عن قضيتهم بل وممارسه
يعني
على قاتهم في الملا امام الناس مش محتاجين
نبحث عن امثله بعيده لان قطر
اللي بتستضيف كاس العالم خلال ايام مورثه
ويمارس عليها ضغوط كبيره جدا حتى تسمح
للمثليين
بالتظاهر ورفع اعلامهم بالمخالفه للقوانين
الموجوده في قطر وفي غير قطر الدول اللي
بتعارض ممكن تحرم من تنظيم بعض هذه
البطولات
في في الغرب دلوقتي ما يمكن ان يسمى بلوبي
الدفاع عن المثليين لوبي حقيقي بيضم
شخصيات مهمه وعندهم جهود منظمه وفي اكثر
من 15 جمعيه ومنظمه كبيره تعادل اللوبي
اليهودي ولوج السلاح ولوبي هذا اللوبي
المعني بالدفاع عن حقوق المثليين
والمتحولين جنسيا في الغرب وفي كل مكان في
العالم له لا يكتفي بانه يروج لافكاره من
خلال الدراما ومن خلال الضغط على
السياسيين والشركات الكبيره ده بيعيد
قراءه التاريخ من منظور الهويه الجنسيه
وبيقول لنا دلوقت انه
يوليس قيصر كان يعني مثلي الجنسيه
الاسكندر الاكبر كان مثلي الجنسيه
شكسبير ليوناردو فينشي الملك جيمس السادس
ال ال ال ال ال البريطاني وغيرهم يعني
اعاده قراءه التاريخ ليس لفهمه من زاويه
اخرى ولكن فقط
لا يصير رساله ان الشخصيات التاريخيه
الكبيره المؤثره ديت كانت مثلي كانوا من
مثلي الجنسيه ولو كان عندهم القدره وقتها
ان يكونوا من المتحولين لا فعله
بالمناسبه الاصرار الشديد من جانب الغرب
ده مش بس مثير للدهشه
لنا او لي الدول او العالم خارج الغرب ده
مثير للدهشه ايضا لقطاعات واسعه للغرب
ببساطه لانه في قطاع محافظ يميني متدين
اذا كان مسيحي او غير مسيحي في الغرب يرفض
هذا التوجه ولكنه يقف عاجزا امامهم
ومندهش لانه اصلا حركه الدفاع عن حقوق
المثليين اللي هي بتقفز خطوات واسعه جدا
كانت حتى وقت قريب يعني غير موجوده حتى
نهايه الستينات ما كانش فيه حركه تذكر
للدفاع عن حقوق المثليين
واقدر لكم تاريخ حركه الدفاع عن حقوق
المثليين والمتحولين جنسيا في دقائق قليله
لانها قصيره جدا هي عمرها حوالي 50 سنه
والمحطات المؤثره فيها ليست كثيره ولو انت
عاوز تتكلم عن تاريخ وجذور ظاهره الدفاع
عن حقوق الانسان تقدر ترجع يعني له سنه 69
دي كانت سنه يعني نقطه تحول في تاريخ هذه
الحركه ايه اللي حصل سنه 69 وتحديدا في 28
يونيو ان شرطه نيويورك كده همك احد
البارات ده كان يعني بيتادوا همم اللي هم
المثليين جنسيا والشرطه دهمته ليه سبب
رئيسي انه كان بتديره مافيا وفقا ل- يعني
معظم الروايات والمفادي كانت
بتتاجر في الخمور المهربه فالشرطه اللي
داهمت البار اكثر من مره ارادت ان تضع
يدها على الخمور المربه وفي نفس الوقت
تلقي القبض او تطرد رواده من المثليين لان
ده كان ايضا ممنوع في ال- على الاراضي
الامريكيه وقتها اللي حصل في هذا اليوم ان
حدثت اشتباكات وفي روايات كثيره كتبت عن
هذه الواقعه طبعا من وجهه نظر مجتمع علميه
او المثليين ومن وجهه نظر يعني اخرين لكن
الخلاصه انه
ان الاشتباكات ديه التاسعه من نطاقها و
ااا تم تسليط الصحافه عليها الاضواء عليها
كثيرا والبعض بيقول انه اللي هما
المدافعين عن حقوق المثليين ان دي كانت
بذره او باكوره انتفاضه المثليين للدفاع
عن حقوقهم وانضم اليهم من غير المثليين
متعاطفين ضد الشرطه الغاشمه التي لا يجب
ابدا ان تعامل مواطنين بهذه القسوه لمجرد
ان لهم قويه جنسيه مختلفه في روايه اخرى
بتقول ان ده حصل بس في مبالغه وان الجزء
الاكبر مما نشتبه مع الشرطه كانوا من
اصحاب المقهى ومن المثل اللي بتدير المقهى
وتستفيد من وجوده على كل الاحوال كانت هذه
اللي واقعه نقطه تحول لانشاء حركه الدفاع
عن حقوق المثليين واصحاب الهويه الجنسيه
المختلفه وفي العام التالي في نفس اليوم
28 يونيو سنه 70 بدات ما يسمى بالبرايد
مارش او مسيره الفخر
اللي بدات تسير في الشوارع احياء لذكرى
ااا البار اللي كان اسمه استون وول في 28
يوليو 69 المسيره باختصار بتقول للناس نحن
لنا حقوق ولا يجب ان نعامل كاننا مجرمين
ثم بدات هذه المسيره تذهب في كل العواصم
الغربيه همم بانتظام واكتسبت اهميه كبيره
في السنوات الاخيره واصبح على المشاهير في
هذه الدول ان يدعمها هؤلاء المثليين في
يوم مسيره الفخر بكلمات تعدد من قضيتهم
وتدعمهم الى اخرهم على كل الاحوال محطه
ثانيه جاءت سنه 78 بعد المسيره ديت ابتدات
بعض الشخصيات تتشجع وتعلن عن هويتها سنه
78 كان في شخصيه من هذه الشخصيات اسمه
هارفي ملك على ما اذكره وكان شراء يعني
طبعا كان مثل الجنسيه وكان مسؤول كبير في
كاليفورنيا وله شعبيه
ده القى خطاب في هذا العام عن 78
خطاب مؤثر بيوجه في
حديثه لاصحاب الهويه الجنسيه المختلفه
ويقول لهم اعلنوا عن هوياتكم لا تخشوا من
رد افعال اصدقائكم وذويكم لو كانوا
اصدقاءكم فعلا لو كانوا فعلا يعني من
محبيكم هيقبلوكم كما انتم اعلنوا عن
هويتكم اخرجوا الان الان الان
وبالتالي كلام المؤثر ده شجع عدد كبير جدا
خصوصا من المشاهير ان يعلنوا عن هوياتهم
الجنسيه
وتطورت المسائل ووصلنا في 2015 عشان نجد
انه المحكمه الدستوريه العليا في امريكا
بتقر بمبدا الزواج من نفس الجنس وتقول انه
لا يحق لاي ولايه من الولايات الامريكيه
ان تعترض على الزواج من نفس الجنس السيده
تتزوج سيده والرجل يتزوج رجل ودي كانت
نقطه مفصليه وترتب عليها كثير من القوانين
المربكه من ناحيه وداعمه لحركه المثليين
والمتح الجنسيه
وهي داعمه ليس فقط للمثليين في الولايات
المتحده ولكن خارجها في اللحظه اللي انا
بكلمكم فيها دي 2022 في حوالي 32 دوله حول
العالم تقر بحق المثليين في الزواج من نفس
الجنس وطبعا معظم هذه الدول في الكتله
الغربيه او كل الدول تقريبا في الكتله
الغربيه
ال- ال- ال- المساله مره ثانيه بنعيد ده
تاريخ الحركه احنا رحنا السؤال ومظاهر
الالحاح والتراخ وطرحنا تاريخ حركه حقوق
الدفاع عن المثليين بشكل سريع لكن يبقى
السؤال بقى سر الالحاح والحماس الشديد جدا
من الغرب للترويج للحقوق المثليين
والمتحولين جنسيا الحقيقه السؤال ده بيطرى
على ناس كثيره وناس كثيره بتحاول تجتهد في
الاجابه يعني مثلا لما سوء الهذا السؤال
سيرجي لافاوف وزير الخارجيه روسيا في هذا
العام قال لا اعلم والله مش عارف ايه سر
هذا الحماس الكبير حقوق الانسان كثيره ليه
ده من بين الحقوق اللي بتحضر بكل هذا
الاهتمام من الغرب لان الغرب ذهب في
الدفاع والترويج لهذا الحق الى حدود
احيانا تثير الضحك يعني يبقى وسائل
الاعلام غربيه
بتلتقي زعماء في دول فقيره جدا زي افريقيا
وانا شفت ثلاث انترفيوس وسائل الاعلام
مثل السي ان ان بتقابل زعماء افارقه وبدلا
من ان يسالوهم عن
المشاكل الجوع التنميه الفقر الاستقرار
السياسي يسر على طرح سؤال اساسي عن موقف
هؤلاء الزعماء من حقوق المثليين
والمتحولين جنسيا الاجابات عاده بتاتي
الدبلوماسيه زي يعني هذه ثقافتنا اتركنا
وشاننا واحد قال لهم
ليس في افريقيا مثليين يعني همم وبالتالي
القضيه ليست مطروحه واحد ثاني قال لهم
والله كان رئيس كينيا قال لهم يعني كينيا
عندها مشاكل اخرى هذا ليس من الاولوياتنا
لما الحوا على رئيس على رئيس اوغندا وانا
باضع لحضراتكم رابط حوار يعني قال لهم هذا
امر مقزز انا لم اكن اعلم ما يفعلونه لكن
ما ان علمت حتى ادرك كم هم مقززون وطبعا
كلامه اثار رد فعل غاضبه جدا في الغرب ودي
قصه يطول شرحها على العموم لما سوق
اللبروف ايه سر الهوس الغربي الحديث عن
حقوق المثليين وهم في الاخر اقليه صغيره
جدا جدا جدا وللمتحولين جنسيا بالنسبه لا
تكت تذكر ايه الفكره يعني لا اعلم ولكن
ربما لا يكون جزء من نظريه المليار السعيد
او الجولدن بلين
اللي بيسعى لتقليل عدد سكان الارض نظريه
المليار السعيد دي نظريه او البعض
بيعتبرها نظريه مؤامره ان في بعض النخب
الغربيه اللي بتقول ان موارد الارض ديت لا
يمكن ان تكفل ثمانيه مليار بني ادم يعيشون
عليها انما ممكن تكفي ليه مليار واحد
والمليارد واحد دول هيكونوا عيشه بسعاده
لان الموارد هتكون كافيه جدا لهم وبالتالي
وفقا لهذه النظريه الشائعه في بعض الدول
ومنها روسيا ان النخب الغربيه بتحاول ان
هي همم يعني تقلص عدد سكان الارض قادره ما
تستطيع بالمناسبه ماهاتير محمد رئيس وزراء
ماليزيا الشهير السابق قال كلاما مشابها
لما سئل الدكتور عبد الوهاب المسيري
المفكر المصري الشهير المرحوم الدكتور عبد
الوهاب المسيري قال تفسيرا مختلفا طب ليه
الدكتور عبد الوهاب المسيري يعني المفكرين
كثيرين مش بس لانه مفكر مرموق ولكن لانه
مهتم بهذه القضيه من وقت مبكر جدا منذ ان
كان يعد رساله الدكتوراه في الولايات
المتحده وبدا الحديث عن هذه الظاهره اللي
هو كان مندهش لها وتوصل له تفسير ان سبب
اهتمام الغرب من وقت المبكر بهذه
الظاهره المثليه الجنسيه والهويات الجنسيه
المختلفه فقط لانه حضاره مرفها جدا
وبتبحث عن الملفات هي شبعت من الملفات
العاديه لم يعد يشبع بعضا من من يعيشون في
الغرب من الرجال والنساء ان هم يستمتعوا
بالعلاقات الطبيعيه فبيبحثوا عن على قد
غير طبيعيه املا في ان يجدوا مزيدا من
اللذه والده جزء من فلس ال هدوزم الهدوء
نزل يعني البحث عن اللذه في كل مكان وقال
انه اللي بيمارس المثليه الجنسيه والهويات
الجنسيه الاخرى
بيذكره بالرومان اللي كانوا الاول قبل ما
يكون مرفعين بيستمتعوا بالاكل مثل باقي
البشر ثم اصبحوا اكثر رفاهيه فبائي يعني
يسرفوا في الاكل ثم لما اصبحوا اكثر واكثر
رفاهيه بقى بعضهم ياكل ثم يذهب ويتقيا
ليستمتع بمزيد من الاكل وقال انه اضاف
يعني الدكتور عبد الوهاب المسيري ومره
اخرى انا واضع لحضراتكم رابط ما قال
وما كتب انه دي كمان مرتبطه بشيء اخر انها
لذه بلا ثمن يعني ايه لذه بلا ثمن الا ان
علاقه الرجل والسيده الرجل والمراه بيترتب
عليها اطفال واسره والتزامات
ويعني من ابجديات اللذه المطلقه اللي يكون
هناك توابع للذه لا يريدون ان تكون هناك
توابع وارتباط واثر الى اخره
الغربي بيقولوا انتم تعبين نفسكم بمحاوله
توقيت يعني ايجاد تفسيرات لقضيه واضحه
المساله بالنسبه لنا ليست الا دفاعا عن
حقوق الانسان
المثليين والراغبين في التحول الجنسي فئه
مثل اي فئه اخرى يجب ان تحترم حقوقهم
خصوصا بانه علماؤنا هكذا يقول الغرب
توصلوا لنتيجه ما كانتش معروفه فيما مضى
من الزمن فيما مضى من الزمن في الغرب
والشرق كان بينظر الى المثليين الجنسيين
على انهم منحرفين يجب عقابهم العلم اثبت
وفقا له كلام بعض الناس في الغرب ان هكذا
خلقهم الله وبما ان هكذا خلقهم الله فياجب
احترامهم زي ما بنحترم الاسود والابيض
والقصير والطويل بنحترب اللي هو عنده هويه
جنسيه مختلفه ده اللي كان بيقولوا في
الاول ثم تطور حديثهم وخطبهم وقالوا
دي طبيعتهم وقالوا حتى لو مش طبيعتهم في
هذا اختيارهم ويجب احترام اختيار
الانسان عاوز يكون يعني انسان عادي عاوز
يكون عنده هويه جنسيه هذا اختياره وله
الحمد
وفي تقديري كل تفسير منهم ممكن ممكن يفسر
جزء من الظاهره ولكن لا يعطي تفسيرا كاملا
يعني الحديث عن المليار السعيد اولا
بيفترض ان في نخبه شريره موجوده بتخطط
للقضاء على سبعه مليار انسان او تقليل
اعدادهم يجوز يكون ده توجه موجود عند بعض
المتطرفين في الغرب لكن لا يمكن ان يكون
تفسيرا للدفاع دول الغربيه كثيره عن حقوق
المثليين ثم ليس لنا دليل على وجود هذه
النخبه اللي بتتامر على الكره الارضيه
كلام الدكتور عبد الوهاب المسيري في انه
في ناس بتمارس
المثليه كنوع من البحث عن اللد ممكن يفسر
جزء من الظاهره لكن ما يفسرش كل هذا
الحماس الحماس الكبير جدا همم نخب همم
مهمه يعني يعني
خصوصا بانه انا سمعت من رياضي شهير اسمه
ذاهب عن يعني همم عن ذهني الان هو بيقول
انا مازلت صغيرا في السن وهو بيلعب االعاب
قتاليه برازيلي بيقول ايه المانع ان انا
اكسبلور بايسكش واليتي ان انا يعني استطلع
ابحث جائز اجد اللذه في ان انا اكون عندي
هويه جنسيه اخرى لم اكتشفها ده مفهوم بس
ما يقدرش يفسر الظاهره كلها لانه لو انسان
عادي طبيعي الغالبيه لم تجد لذه في ان
يكون مثلي الجنسيه ممكن تكون فئه لمره لكن
ظاهره صعب ان ده يقدم تفسير كامل
في تفسير الرابع في تقديره يضيف الى
التفسيرات الثلاثه وهي انه
انك تكون ان في شخص يكون عنده هويه جنسيه
مختلفه هي اقليه صحيح ولكنها اقليه عابره
للعرق
اقليه عابره للون اقليه عابره للدين يعني
مثلا كل الاقلبيات التي طهطت في الغرب
لسنوات طويله ثم بدا التبحث عن حقوقك نزلت
يعني اليهود ما زالوا يهودا المسلمين ما
زالوا اقليه العرب ما زالوا اقليه
الاسيويين الى اخرهم الصوت طبعا
انما لما بيكون شخص عنده هويه جنسيه ممكن
تكون مسلم
وعندك هويه جنسيه مختلفه ممكن تكون مسيحي
ممكن تكون يهودي ممكن تكون
اسود يمكن ان تكون اسيوي وعندك هويه ممكن
تكون مثلي ويمكن ان تكون ابيض مسيحي في
الغرب ومثلي الجنسيه والرجل او الانسان
الابيض رجل وسيده ومسيحي هم دول مركز
القوه والنفوذ في الغرب فاذا كان هناك
منهم من هو مثل الجنسيه فمعنى كده انه دول
هيكون عندهم دافع اكبر بشكل
مختلف للدفاع عن حقوق المثليين الناس على
دين ملوكهم وملوك الغرب ومراكز النفوس
فيها بتتركز في
الانسان الابيض المسيحي
الكلام ده انشائي طب تعالوا نخليه من
انشائي الى كلام يبقى ليس انشائيا يعني
حركه الدفاع عن حقوق المثليين اكتسبت زخبا
كبيرا جدا لما في شخصيات مؤثره ومهمه من
نخبه النقب في الولايات المتحده والغرب
دافعت عن حقوقهم الولايات المتحده اكبر
حزبين فيها الجمهوري والديمقراطي وفي
شخصيات مؤثره من الحزبين دافعه عن حقوق
المثليين الجمهوري طبعا حزب
بيغلب عليه الطابع اليمين المحافظ اللي
اغلبيته بيرفض و اا يعني يتحفظ على الدفاع
عن حقوق المثليين لكن منهم شخصيه دافعت
بحماس منهم على سبيل المثال ديكتين انا
بدي مثل واحده عشان الوقت طب دي بتشيلي ده
اللي كان وزير دفاع ونائب رئيس جمهوريه
ومن اقطاب الجمهوريين دافع مؤخرا حقوق
المثليين ليه ببساطه لانه عنده ابنتين
واحده منهم عندها هويه جنسيه مختلفه
وبالتالي وخرج على ان تعاطفا مع ابنته
للدفاع عن حقوق المثليين دعما لابنتهم
طب من الديمقراطيين اوباما وما ادراك ما
اوباما وشعبيته بين الديمقراطيين وكثير من
الامريكان وخصوصا السود دافع عن حقوق
المثليين ولما دافع ده اثر على قبول عدد
كبير جدا من الامريكان وخصوصا السود
وبداوا يرحبوا
بمبدا او الزواج من نفس الجنس وحقوق
المثليين والمتحولين جنسيا ده عن
السياسيين طيب في شخصيات مؤثره في الاعلام
ممكن يكون انت راجل مهم جدا وعندك
استثمارات ضخمه في الحديد او الخشب او
الصناعات المختلفه لكن نفودك يقتصر على
على المساحه اللي انت ترغب في ممارسه هذا
النفوذ ممكن لا تمارسه ابدا انما من يعمل
في قطاع الاعلام سواء اراد او لم يرد هو
قادر على ان يصل الى الناس ويؤثر فيهم
بشكل مباشر واكثر بكثير يعني مثال واحد
انه رئيسه ديزني شركه ديزني
قالت انا عندي اثنين واحد منهم
مزدوج الجنسيه يعني يمارس العلاقات مع
الاناث والذكور والاخر متحول جنسيا
وبالتالي كام اللي متحول جنسيا وثنائي
الجنسيه فانا ارغب في ان ارى ماني ماني
ماني شخصيات كثيره جدا جدا جدا في الافلام
التي ننتجها تعبر او تمثل عن شخصيات
ممثليه الجنسيه او من المتحولين جنسيا
الخلاصه ان احنا قدامنا لوفي وانه اللوبي
ده اصبح بالغ النفوس الى درجه ان بعض رجال
الدين في الكنائس الكنائس زي كل الاديان
الاخرى عندها موقف بتحرم فيه المثليه
الجنسيه والتحول الجنسي اصبحوا عاجزين عن
ان يصفوا المثليه الجنسيه بانها خطيئه حتى
لا يتعرضوا لضغوط هائله
اللوبي ده تعرض لانتكاسه لما جاءت اداره
لما وصل ترامب الى السلطه والترامب بيمثل
اليمين المحافظ في الولايات المتحده او في
الغرب اللي هو عنده موقف طبعا رافض له
حقوق المثليين
والمتحولين جنسيا ترامب لم يعبر عن ذلك
علنا لان ده قضيه حساسه هناك الان لكنه
اتخذ مجموعه من الاجراءات التي اعتبرها
هذا اللوبي معاديه له زي مثلا انه رفض انه
المتحولين جنسيا يلتحق
القوات المسلحه الامريكيه زي انه رفض
تشريع كان ابابا كان رئيس اوباما يرغب في
تمريره يعني يعطي وضع عن همم يعطي حمايه
للمتحولين جنسيا في المدارس الى اخره لكن
لما خرج ترامب من السلطه عبر عن موقفه
علنا وقال التعليم عندنا قال الكلام ده في
يونيو الماضي 22 قال التعليم في الولايات
المتحده عجيبه غريب
تاون تذكر انت ايديكيشن سيستم السوق اب
سايد داون ليه ابسايد داون من وجهه نظر
ترامب لانه لا يمكن
تعليم الانجيل في المدارس لكن الاطفال
يتعلمون ان الرجال يمكن ان يحملوا
وان اطفال الروضه يسمح لهم بالانتظار حتى
يختارون نوعهم ذكرا ام انثى
نتيجه انه الرئيس ترامب كان له موقف معادي
لحقوق المثليين مثل كل اليمين المحافظ او
غالبيه اليمين المحافظ
لما جاء الرئيس وطبعا في حاله استقتاب
عنيفه في الولايات المتحده زي ما الرئيس
ترامب اراد ان يمحو كل ما فعله اوباما
اراد الرئيس بيدن الان ان يمحو كل ما فعله
ترامب وجزء من محاوله محور اثر يعني قرفه
ترامب هو
التوسع جدا جدا في حقوق المثليين
والمتحولين جنسيا وانا قلت لحضراتكم في
اول الحلقه انها اكبر اداره ضمت عددا من
المثليين والمتحولين جنسيا في التاريخ هي
اداره السيد بيضا الاداره الامريكيه
بموقفه الجديد اللي بتعتبر انه الترويج
والدفاع عن حقوق المثليين
والمتحولين جنسيا واجب مقدس وفير قلق
العالم مين العالم زعماء كثيرين انا اشرت
الى موقف الزعماء الافارقه في السياق
وادهشهم كجزء من العالم الثالث من طرح هذه
القضيه وكانها اهم اولويات ومن اهم
اولوياتهم لكن المساله لا تقتصر على دول
العالم الثالث فقط يعني رئيس قتل لا يترك
مناسبه الا وهيذكر جمهوره بان الغرب
الفاسد يريد افساد اطفاء اطفالهم ويعني
العبث بها هوياتهم الجنسيه بدون اي سبب
رئيس المجر قال كلمه شهيره بيقول لهم من
فضلكم
امراه والرجل همم والاب رجل اتركه اطفالنا
وشانههم ايه القصه ديت القصه ردا على
الغرب اللي بيقول له انه المراه او الام
اللي يجب ليست بالضروره ان تكون امراه
ممكن يكون رجل وان الرجل ممكن يحمل وانه
ممكن الاسره تتكون من ذكرين او من سيدتين
وانه الاطفال همم لا يجب ابدا ان احنا
نفرض عليه مهاويتهم الجنسيه حين يولده
لننتظر ونرى فبالتالي بيقول لهم اتركونا
وشاننا هذا امر غير
قل
عاوز اذكر حضراتكم ان اللي بيتحفظ على
الحمل الغربيه الهائله الان مش بيتحفظ على
انه الغرب بيقول ان في مثليين ويجب الدفاع
عن حقوقهم ده مقبول في بعض الدول
مقبول ان حد يقول له ان العلم بيقول ان في
شخص اتولد
بوضع مختلف وانه ولد هذا الانسان ولد على
انه ذكر وانه محتاج انه يتحول الى انثى
لان في خلل ده ممكن يكون مفهوم لكن اللي
مش مفهوم هو اللي انا اشرت اليه دلوقتي ان
الغرب تجاوز الامور دي علشان يقول انه
انه مش بس ان انا دافع عن حقوق شخص مثل
الجنسيه لا ده انا عاوز اعطي فرصه ان
الناس تستطلع وتجرب انت عايش رجل انت
عايشه سيده بس يعني جربوا جهز تستمتعه
اكثر بكونكم يعني من الجنس الاخر فتش عن
الانثى التي في داخلك فتششي عن الرجل الذي
في داخلك الاطفال اللي ما عندهمش مشاكل
وواضح ان ما عندهمش خلل فيها هوياتهم
الجنسيه ليه انا اصر على ان انا اعتبر ان
التسجيل جنسهم في شهادات الميلاد مصادره
على حقوقهم في المستقبل
احنا كان عندنا الدفاع عن حقوق المثليين
عباره عن اربع حروف الاربع حروف دول انا
كنت فاهمهم ببساطه انا باقول مجتمع
المثليين من اول الحلقه وانا اقصد الكلمه
الانجليزيه ال جي بي تي الال اللي هي
اختصار ليزبين اللي هي السيدات اللي عندها
اللي ترغب في اقامه علاقات مع السيدات
والجي اللي هم الرجال الذي يرغب في اقامه
علاقه مع الرجال البي اللي هو مزدوجي
الهويه الجنسيه بيقيم علاقه مع الاثنين
والتين اللي هم المتحولين جنسيا ده كان
مفهوم
وده كانت قضيه شائكه لكن الغرب جعلها اكثر
اربيكا لما قالوا انتم فاهمين غلط الموضوع
مش بس هم الاربع حروف دول او الاربع
حلويات دول لا لا المساله اكبر بكثير
واضافلها الكيو واضافولها الاي واضافولها
الايه وهما دون في اضافه حروف تمثل عن
هويات جنسيه مختلفه انا حاولت افهمها
والله ما فهمت يعني انا فاهم الاربعه
الاولانيين فعلا حاولت وما فهمتش وحاطط
لحضراتكم رابط لهويات جنسيه كثيره جدا هم
بيقولوا انها متميزه ومختلفه وانه الجنس
البشري لا يقتصر على الرجل ولا على المراه
واصبحت واصبح اللوبي
المثليه الجنسيه او لو بالال جي بي تي كيو
اي اي بي يلاحق اي بي اي عالم يقول ان
الانسان رجل وامراه فقط واصبح من المطروح
الان تعريف المراه وفي حرج انه يقولوا ان
الحمل قصر على المراه وفي حوار شهير بين
احد اعضاء الكونجرس واستاذه في الجامعه
متحفضه ان تقول ان النساء لما بتحمل
وبتقول الانسان لما بيحمل وسؤلها ما تقول
السيدات قالت له لا ما قلتش السيدات ممكن
الرجال يريد ان يحملوا وبالتالي المساله
مربكه جدا تجاوزت الدفاع اللي هو اصلا
مثير له
الجدل ومربك عن حقوق المثليين ليه افاق
مربك جدا عن هويه الانسان ويقول له الغيت
محاضره في مايو الماضي على ما اذكر في
المانيا لان عالمه البيولوجي اللي كانت
تتحدث همم محاضرتها بتقول ان العلم لا
يعرف الا الذكر والانثى فثارت يعني همم
مظاهرات واحتجاجات واقول غيه المحاضره ما
لها زخروف قالت ساخره اللي هي المتحدثه
باسم خارجيه روسيا لدينا لدينا تقول روسيا
الدول الاخرى يعني اللي هي غالبيه العظمى
من البشر
رجل وامراه ولديهم 80 نوع يربقهم ويربقنا
وينذر به اخبار كثيره جدا اشكركم والى
لقاءات اخرى باذن الله